هو بالتحديد في فلسطين حيث استقبلت مؤسسه
سيده الارض عددا من الفنانين والشعراء
والاعلاميين العرب
وايضا استقبلت عدد من الشخصيات الدوليه
والعربيه المرموقه للمشاركه في مؤتمرنا
الثانوي الخامس خالد القاسم كان هناك
ه جديده يتناولها الفنان المصري احمد بدير
هذه المره في رام الله
فنانون واعلاميون وسياسيون عرب ودوليون
يكرمون اليوم في مدينه رام الله كمتنان
فلسطيني على دعمهم للقضيه الفلسطينيه
والله انا من ساعه ما جيت وانا ما فيش في
دماغي الا في فلسطين واننا في هذه الارض
المباركه الطيبه
وسعيد بالحاله اللي انا فيها انما مبدئيا
انا ان شاء الله في لما انزل مسلسل اسمه
حضره العمده ده لرمضان ان شاء الله
الاولى
باكثر عمق لاني اعرف بعض الاماكن اعرف بعض
الازقه احفظ كذلك بعض الاسماء والاشعار عن
ظهر قلب لذلك اعدته زياره هذه الاماكن
نفسها مثل ما تحفه محمود همم درويش مثل
كذلك متحف همم ابو عمار لكن هنالك مسيره
اخرى القدس ايضا كنت البارحه همم في القدس
وكانني نزلت من القمر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا المهرجان يقام سنويا لتكريم شخصيات
عامه دعمت او اعلنت التعاطفها مع القضيه
الفلسطينيه على المنابر الدوليه كي يتسنى
للمكرمين التعرف على فلسطين انقر ناخذ هذا
الفنان الذي كان له دور متراكم عبر عبر كل
هذه السنوات مع القضيه الفلسطينيه ومن ثم
في اخر اوقات هذا هذا العام بيتم الاختيار
بهذا الاتجاه ومن ثم يتم دعوتهم لحضور
المهرجان كضيوف شرف او مكرمين
تظاهرات فنيه من العيار الثقيل فنجسمها
الفنان الكبير احمد بدير بصفته شخصيه
العام في الدراما العربيه
الفنان القدير احمد بدير قاد مسرحيه
الصعايده وصلوا واليوم يقود الفنانين
والاعلاميين السفراء والوزراء هنا الى رام
الله ومع ذلك لن يكون الفنان احمد الدير
حضره العمده في رمضان القادم من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خالد القاسم العربيه